I have a team here
that came with one idea,
and they already pivoted
two or three times.
We have a team that came in
and people look at the idea
and they were like, "What?
How am I supposed to analyze this?
I've never heard of something like this."
And we said, "Okay, here's a 100k,
let's work together."
Tal Zackon, thank you
for joining me on 20 minute leaders.
How are you?
Thank you for having me.
It's great to be here.
Calling straight
from the F2 offices, right?
Yes. Actually, as you said,
the lighting was not good
in my office, I'm in my partner's office.
It's my aspiring position.
I love that.
I definitely love that.
Tal, can we talk about pre-seed.
F2 Capital, the junction
that one of my best friends, Mickey,
has also had the pleasure
of being a part of,
but also, about the interesting journey
of both being
one arm in startup scene and
one arm in the investment scene,
and you know,
cross bordering the insights.
But before we get there,
tell me a little bit about your journey,
and how do you find yourself
in venture capital?
Sure.
Well, you know, I actually,
I told this story a few times.
So, do you want to start
from South Africa
where I was born
or should I go straight forward
to me joining the F2?
If we had enough time,
we would go back
to when your parents were born.
Bute we'll start when you were born.
Okay, cool.
So, I'm originally
from Cape Town, South Africa.
I moved to Israel
when I was five, with my parents.
I'm not going to go into that
my whole childhood story
but when I was 18,
I joined the army,
I joined the Special Forces
Intelligence Unit.
And then after the army after six years,
serving as a combatant and a captain,
went to study to IDC business.
And for my studies,
I did an exchange program at USC,
University of Southern California.
So, I was about 26 at the time,
and then all the others around me
were about, youngest were like 18,
straight out of the high school
into college.
And some of the other exchange guys
were like 21, 22.
And in Israel it's not common
to have internships.
And all my friends,
were like, yeah, I'm going back home,
I'm going to be working
for Morgan Stanley, JP Morgan, McKinsey.
And I was like, "Man,
I have a semester
that I have nothing to do.
What should I be up to?"
So, I decided to be proactive
and reach out
to bunch of VCs on LinkedIn.
Until this day
I say that any VC in Israel,
if they go into their LinkedIn inbox,
they'll find a message from me
from like, 2017 saying,
Hi, my name is Tal
and I want to work for you.
I think none of them responded seriously.
One did, Johnny Saacks from a F2 VC.
And before that of course,
he was at Genesis.
He said, "Let's meet for coffee."
I came to meet him.
I asked to join. He said, "No."
I said, "Please."
He said, "Okay."
That's the short version.
And two days after, I started at F2.
And since then I've been
at the fund for three years.
Wow.
Tell me a little bit about F2 about,
about some of the insights
that you've had at F2,
but also about what F2 is all about
as a venture capital fund.
Sure. Sure.
So, F2, we are seed stage
specialized venture capital firm,
investing in Israeli
early stage companies.
We believe that's all about the people,
It's all about the founders.
We put the founders in the center
and we do everything we can
to be an extension
of their core founding team.
We invest in deep technology,
focusing on machine learning, AI,
big data connectivity.
So, it's pretty general,
but there has to be some
kind of aspect leveraging data
or machine learning internally.
Now, you know these are buzzwords,
but we do have the capabilities
in terms of network
and in-house knowledge
to really determine
if this is real technology
and leveraging state of the art machinery
and data science.
As part of F2, we also have
the platform called the Junction,
which is the pre-seed platform.
And that's kind of our premise
to the ecosystem.
So, we go much earlier than anyone else.
So, besides investing C stage,
which is the core business,
we also do pre-seed investments.
And that's when we see a team
that we feel the risk
is too high for putting in
a couple of million dollars,
so, we will invite them
to come sit at our office
at the same time
and also, give them all the variance,
we give our preferred companies
while also investing on a safe,
a few hundred case
and working with them towards
the seed round.
So, tell me a little bit about
the pre-seed in general.
It's very rare that a proper VC goes
and writes pre-seed checks
or present at the forefront.
You're actually the general manager
of the Junction.
So, what is the junction?
And what are some
of the thought process behind pre-seed?
I did meet a few very interesting people
that are in Palo Alto
that are working on the assumption that,
you know,
by reaching the founders early
and going through the journey
and actually when you reach
the millions of dollars of checks,
you actually have much more data
to base your due diligence on.
I know that 15, 18 fund,
it's a relatively new fund.
They write even thousand dollar checks
to founders as a gift,
no equity, just to get to know them
and to go on their journey with them.
But tell me a little bit about
what the thesis behind the junction.
I think that,
as you described it very well,
it's about building a relationship.
So, all founders,
especially first timers around,
walking around the ecosystem
trying to raise funds,
and it's very important to understand
that they aren't competing
only against the companies
that are doing what they are doing.
They are competing against
any other startup
that has been established,
all went to fundraising
in the past two months.
So, that's a very difficult competition.
And the process of raising funds
can take even six months
if you are really having
a hard time proving the value
of what you are doing,
and you also need a team
to believe in you.
What we offer at Junction
is a very quick
due diligence process
that takes about a week.
And we can offer at the end,
100, 200, $300,000
and offer them to come work with us
and build a relationship
with a venture capital firm.
So, we also provide all this knowledge
and this knowledge base
of how venture capital firms work.
And also from our experience
working with startups,
we can advise them
on what's the best thing to do.
So, we have teams here
that came with these crazy ideas
that all the VCs said like, no,
and we were able
to build a relationship,
help them build the business
and develop the idea
and then go and launch
a very successful seed round.
In 2019, we had
a few companies come through.
And I think all of them,
one maybe out of the 18 raise,
but all of them raised seed rounds
from really well-known
Israeli seed funds.
So, it's about building the relationship,
understanding how the VC ecosystem works,
bringing the value add
and building the relationship,
which is really, really important
because they get to know us
and they will understand if they want
to even work with us in the future,
and we get to know them.
It's a six-month or four-month
live due diligence.
It's like the best thing, both sides.
So, the pre-seed, you know,
from my perspective,
pre-seed stage really is a few people
that have a passion,
that found a cumulative passion together,
they think they have the right expertise
to go and tackle the problem.
The not usually
don't even have a product
let alone product market fit,
they go and they want to raise funds
that they were able to come
and bring some into fruition,
possibly even get a few clients
to raise a proper seed round.
Is that too early to talk about VC?
Because from one perspective,
you can say that
at the pre-seed stage,
you really should be focusing
on being with a team together
working day and night
and getting that technology there.
But it sounds to me that
from your perspective,
it's not too early
because getting those relationships
can only be beneficial
as you actually go in
and want to raise
a meaningful round later on.
I think that these benchmarks of,
if I have a presentation
and then I have customers, can I raise?
If I have $100,000 in MRR, can I raise?
These are discussions
that I think founders try
and understand the formula
of how VCs work.
There's no formula.
There are different risks
that some VCs feel more comfortable with
and some that others don't.
And that's how it works.
If I see a team with great potential,
and I feel like I want to work with them
and it's something that
I can do with them
and they are targeting
an interesting problem
or an interesting market,
they still aren't quite sure,
but if I feel that
if I can work with them
for the next few months
they will be able to build something
then I would like to work with them.
And it's okay if they have a presentation
and they haven't even written
a line of code.
I have a team here
that came with one idea
and they already pivoted
two or three times.
We have a team that came in
and people look at the idea
and they were like, "What?
How am I supposed to analyze this?
I've never heard of something like this."
And we said, "Okay, here's a 100K,
let's work together."
Fast forward four months,
one million dollars are raised.
It's going to YC starting in two weeks.
Things, you know, things develop.
You just need to look at the team
and see the potential
and take a bet
and what we do here is that
because our core business
is the seed investing,
a pre-seed investment is kind of,
I wouldn't say cheap
but easy for us to deploy
and take those kind of bets.
Betting with the seed round
is more difficult
because at the end of the day,
we only have 15 bullets
that we can shoot during
the active lifetime of the fund.
100%
So, at the end,
when it comes down to the seed round,
how does the due diligence process
look like for a company
that you've been following along
with the Junction through the pre-seed?
Is it basically, you know,
tell us when you're ready to raise
and then we'll sort of know already
if it is, or do you do the whole process
as if it's a new company?
How does that actually work tangibly?
So, it's actually very different
because we've been working with them
and have these biweeklies
and these ongoing discussions.
We are super up to date
with what's going on with the company.
So, sometimes we will even be proactive
and come to come and say,
"Hey guys, this is time to scale.
We're going to be leading
a four million dollar round.
Let's go for it."
You can also bring the follow up
like, we will do this for you.
And sometimes they'll be like,
"Okay, now we want the money."
And we'll sit down and say,
are we ready, are we not.
Should we offer them
another two months
and then go for the raise.
So, it's kind of this
very friendly discussion
in order to optimize for both sides.
It sounds like a really, mainly,
it takes away a lot of the stress
of considering, okay
how are we going to be able to fundraise
and who do we fundraise from
and how do we allocate now
five months of our CEO's time
to just go on this road show
where you can have
this invaluable partner that not only
gives you that $300,000 in the beginning,
but gets you to the place
where you can be confident yourself
about whether you're able to raise
the proper seed round.
And by that, obviously,
we're not talking about the metrics
that we're talking about,
whether you're actually creating
a viable business
that could actually be impactful right?
100%.
And one more thing, you have fun.
I mean, it's fun.
The vibe here is incredible.
I have different startups coming
for seed round discussions
with different people from the ecosystem
and you come into the office
and this kind of this,
this really cool buzz of like
think about we have about
at the moment,
we have five startups sitting here, okay?
One of the startups, as I said,
grew to almost 12 people.
They are in our office, [--] for them.
I love them.
They are catching all the meeting ups.
Anyway, the buzz of something
is always happening,
all these meeting rooms
are filled with people
talking and drawing on the boards,
and do this and do that.
And this kind of a sense of community
and we have happy hours.
So, I'm fortunate
because I get to work also at a VC fund,
but also with five stops
at the same time.
So, you get of like really
alternative kind of environment
that you're not really used to
when you enter
a venture capital firms office.
I love that.
So, it's like additionally,
and with a really great segue
to working both
with startups and in VC,
you actually took a little trip down,
startup plane now,
a big trip as head of growth
at Superwise.ai,
while also spending time with F2.
And going back to F2,
you mentioned the [--].
But talk to me a little bit
about this transition.
Why you even do this
and what have you learned
along the way?
Cool.
This has been
kind of this self reflection
that I've been having for the past,
couple of months.
And I think I've discussed
with many people in the ecosystem.
As an investor,
I've heard many times
and I don't have startup experience,
I didn't have until now,
how can you evaluate a company
without really knowing
what a startup is about?
Maybe you should get
some operational experience.
And I've been trying to convince myself
and read studies
that there's no correlation between
people that were operators or investors
that were previously operators
and being a good investor.
And I still think that it's true.
But I feel that I need to gain
some operational experience
and feel what the founders feel.
So, when I say to a founder,
"You know, startups are crazy
and it's really hard work."
Now I can say, yes,
I'm working at a startup
and it sucks, super tough.
And I've been learning so much
from working with the Superwise team.
The company raised $4.5 million
in seed about a year ago.
Hopefully, we'll be going
for an A-round soon.
The team is about 15 people,
so, it's exactly the type of companies
that I would like to work with
because these are the companies
we invest in.
And of course, as a seed investor,
usually when companies get
to B, C, D rounds
the seed investors
kind of a part of the board,
but the growth investors take lead
on how to navigate the company.
So, I think it's very important to,
what's important for me at least
to understand what this
what the company looks like.
So, it's like
building the go to market strategy
and talking to customers
and doing these demos
and follow ups.
And suddenly, from being
on the buying side,
the companies come to me and say,
"Hey, can you invest in my company?"
Now, I need to reach out
to data scientist and say,
"Please, I want to show you a demo
of this product.
I think you'll really gain
from using it."
And they just don't answer.
They just don't get back to me.
Usually they do, just kidding.
I'll tell you, about 20%
of the times they do.
So, that's a lot of fun.
And, you know,
closing a customer,
paying customer,
which is a lot for seed stage startup,
it's like the thrill
and the rush that you get
from something like that is amazing.
And I'm really enjoying myself.
So, it's a great experience.
And I can't even imagine.
What are some
of the most meaningful things
that you're taking with you back to F2
from these few months at Superwise?
Because you're mentioning
that you went through
the self reflective journey
where you're thinking about
what type of skills
or what ever experience that you need
in order to be successful investor
in your mind.
And it sounds to me like you've had
a pretty impactful experience
with Supewise.
I'd love to hear some of those
you know, insights
that you've gained along the way.
Sure.
So, I think, the first thing is hustle.
So, you sit on the board,
I'm talking with your startup,
and you're trying to understand
what the processes
and the sales machine, the KPIs.
And sometimes as,
if I look at myself
as a future board member,
I would understand
that you have to hustle, okay?
You need to do whatever it takes
to get to the next milestone.
You don't have to do things
that are scalable,
I'm not talking about product or technology,
I'm talking more on sales and growth.
Okay?
And to use your connections
and to reach out to people,
you need to do whatever it takes
to score these customers.
And only after you experience
onboarding a few customers,
then you can really sit down
and analyze what you did
the right way,
where you made mistakes,
and then also kind of build
the segmentation of the customers
and how to approach each of them,
and slowly but surely,
then you start building
that marketing sales machine.
So, that's the one thing.
The second thing is measure everything.
Measure everything.
Because there are so many insights
inside those numbers
that will really change your perspective
on how to sell, who to sell to,
A/B testing.
I think sometimes you underestimate them.
You say, "I don't have time for this."
And it's a bit slow at the beginning.
But I think that if you invest
in the infrastructure
of measuring things,
that's a great investment
for the long run
and for the future
and for scaling.
So, those are my two main takeaways.
And I will definitely recommend that
to any of our companies going forward.
I love that.
Biggest tips for pre-seed companies,
for example, that are coming to F2.
Because you really get a chance
to both seed companies, you know,
in their early, early days
and then in the early days of seed.
Right?
So, what are some tips
more for the pre-seed?
Because it's very great to be able to talk
to somebody investing
in pre-seed companies
and seeing a lot of them
and then seeing some of the journey
that they go through.
So, perhaps, what are some
of the most meaningful things
that a group of people
can undergo between the pre-seed and seed
that you have been experiencing now
and you can sort of tell them in advance,
by the way, watch out this
this is going to be important?
Sure. I think,
being in love with your idea
is a challenge
that many companies have.
And when you raise pre-seed,
you need to understand
that you have to be very flexible.
And inputs from the market,
and this friction with customers
is super valuable
and you have to take it into consideration.
Because you might be directed
in totally different direction.
And I think investors,
when you reach the seed round
and you pitch them an idea,
if you can say,
I sold out with this idea
and now I'm pitching this idea.
And this is what I learned
during the past three, four months.
These are the insights
I have on the market.
And that's why I pivoted
and I chose to go for this product
and this solution.
As an investor, I'll be like,
"Wow, okay.
He actually studied the market."
Wasn't happy with his idea,
which means he's coachable and flexible
and he is able to kind of productize
the feedback from the customers.
For me, that's a very positive signal
as an investor.
It sounds amazing.
Tal, I want to thank you
for being so generous with your time.
20 minutes go by fast
but I know that there is so much more
that I wanted to talk about,
whether it's the Junction, F2,
where you're headed next.
But it sounds like
it's a phenomenal journey.
And very similar to you,
I think that I'm on
a pretty similar path
of trying to understand
what does it take to make an impact,
whether it's in investing, as a startup,
as a learner, as anything.
And it sounds like
these different experiences
are invaluable.
And I'm definitely taking
a lot from this conversation.
So, thank you.
But before we leave,
I have to ask you
for the most important question,
which is three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
Sure.
So, I think the first word
would be loyal.
Something that I think
one of the values
that I grew up upon,
being loyal to family and friends.
And I know that people that I love,
I'll do anything for them.
And I think that also
it reflects in how I work with the companies
and how I work at F2.
And in Hebrew, it says "takkana shema".
So, I think that's part
of really being loyal.
The second word would be proactive.
I think that you make
your own luck
and you have to be proactive
and just be out there,
expose yourself, be vulnerable.
It's okay.
I think you can only gain
from doing that.
And the third would be hustle.
I hustled my way into F2.
I hustle to source leads at F2.
I hustle at Superwise to reach these
head of data science
and the machine learning.
And it's all about the hustle.
So, just do hard work and hustle
and do whatever it takes.
So, those are the three words on my mind.
Tal, thank you very, very much.
This is great.
And stay safe and stay healthy.
Cheers. Thanks for having me.
Have a good one.
Of course.